[موسيقى
] أسمي القاهرة مغامرة يومية ، فهناك
مدينة لا يمكن التنبؤ بها بمثل
هذه الطاقة الدافئة والرائعة ، وهذا
عدم القدرة على التنبؤ يتحدث إلي كممثلة
تم تصوير هذه المدينة في العديد من
الزوايا للعديد من العدسات التي نشعر بها
كعرب أننا جميعًا  تعرف القاهرة جيدًا
سينما القاهرة مصر هذه هي الكلمات التي
تتصل على الفور في عقول كل عربي
وأعتقد أن المصريين لديهم شغف حقيقي وسلس
بالأفلام من العشرينات إلى اليوم ،
كل نوع من المشهد
الثقافي بدأ كل موجة ثقافية في وسط المدينة.
العالم العربي ، لذلك يجب أن
تمثل لي الصناعة كما بدأت والتي
تم إنشاؤها الآن لأكثر من
مائة عام ، هذه مجموعة دائمة
لدينا ويمكن تصحيحها مثل أي شيء
يمكنك بالطبع إنها متحركة جدًا ، لذا
يبدو  الحي الذي يتم
تقديمه ، لا أعرف على الأقل في
مائة فيلم على الأقل لدينا استوديوهات
في مصر منذ عام 1908 ولكن هذا المكان
مختلف لأن هذا كان أول
فيلم  تم تأسيسها كصناعة ، كان
أول فيلم أنتجوه هو عام 1935 كان
مع Ed Yeah ، لكن هذا هو أول
فيلم غير صامت تم إنتاجه في
مصر وكان من بطولة استهلاك المنزل
وهو أكبر فيلم مغني في الشرق
الأوسط كان ذلك الوقت.  من
النجوم ربما يكون ثمانين ومائة نجم في ذلك
الوقت ،
هذه غرفة الدعائم الفرعونية لدينا ، هذه
كلها أدوات لمأساة
المنزل العظيم الذي يعد طموحًا للغاية ،
لكن هذا سيكون لجد تونكينيزي
حسنًا ، لذا يتم أخذ كل شيء
بالضبط  يأتي السائل
ولكن حركة الوجوه هي إلى حد كبير
هذا المكان مليء حقًا بالأرجل
مع الروائح مع الضوضاء مع أنه
مثل تراكم تاريخ
السينما المصرية